this was a presentation was put together
in cooperation with Eugenie of Bhutan
one fortune
couldn't make it so we're going to
discuss Oh basically I'm not going to
show you how to you know do these things
directly but the idea is to familiarize
yourself with key concepts in missing
data and to make sure Philly Serie
affiliated researchers who have this
problem which is everyone know what
services we offer and what can be done
okay and what should not be done I might
add - okay so what we're going to do is
have a fairly brief description of
modeling missing data using a Bayesian
approach via wind bugs software how many
of you here are familiar with wind bugs
one okay and basically we're going to
focus however on multiple imputation
methods available in our in particular
the Emilia package which incorporates
some aspects of Bayesian modeling now
there's several elements all that you
need to from now and don't worry I'm
going to send everyone who attends the
slides I will send them to you so you
can relax and you don't have to take
notes the key elements is the number of
cases missing missing per variable the
number of variables missing per case and
the pattern of correlation among the
variables for example I also in addition
to being here at Sarah I also have an
appointment up in internal medicine in
occupational health word for example
they have a dataset just shy of 9
million people and they were bit upset
because they were missing 60,000 I
didn't complete data and I said what you
know if you were working here in
behavioral studies were you know a
hundred people is considered good you
wouldn't worry
now the first thing that we need to be
familiar with is are the types of
missing data the sampling improv process
involves both the selection of units and
the process by which observations become
missing if you think about it and for
valid inference we need to account why
these things are missing even if it is
an educated guess
there are basically three categories of
missingness how many of you are familiar
with these just Jamie
okay first is whoops I should have
capitalized that ah is missing
completely at random and that means that
there's no difference between the
characteristics of those observed and
those missing and this can be tested
with something called littles or m-car
test which I will go into in a little
bit Oh missingness is not related to the
data values either you know the graduate
student left part of the book on the
train or errors in lab results entry
mistakes or subjects in longitudinal
duddy a study subjects drop out of the
study for reasons not related to the
intervention outcome or other variables
okay and that is sort of a gold standard
this is what we want
basically hopefully to detect and the
next is missing at random which is
actually a misnomer because um it isn't
really missing at random it means that
there's a difference but it could be
explained by other variables or data
missing the this depends only on
observed data for example subjects are
missing missing income in a study tend
to be younger you can deal with that on
average than those reporting income you
know that can be dealt with this is the
disaster
not at random and most of the literature
calls it non ignore ball under stand
ibly and the difference cannot be
explained missing this is directly
related to the unobserved data and the
probability of reporting in comes for
example depends on the level of income
and a clinical trial the subjects drop
out because they're to set to come in
for follow-up you know and other
problems here are the consequences all
most of you are aware you would have
bias and the estimates systematically
deviates deviate from the quantity of
interest no bias or if it's m-car but
there's a but bias can occur if it's
either missing at random and missing not
at random okay and especially the
variance or can it can change the
standard errors which of course is what
anchors most statistical analysis so
you're in trouble there and of course
wrong study conclusions okay and the
impact of missing data depends on the
amount of missing data and the mechanism
of missingness these three the
consequences of missing not at random
means that you simply cannot remove the
missingness and do the analysis even if
you seem to have a very large n number
in the case I cited above if out of the
nine million most of the 60,000 people
were missing and dropped out of the
system or we were looking at industrial
accidents is because they had an
industrial accident then running the
remaining data however impressive the N
number is it's going to give you false
results so the remain OTT only the the
remaining data is biased in this case
for example in a study I'm involved in
with the University of Pennsylvania on
earlier late treatment HIV treatment for
infants Oh
in South Africa we had to us assure
ourselves that the women who missed the
second visit that the child was alive
and actually had to have people in South
Africa go and call or find before we
could do anything else because if the
child were if the children were very
sick from their infection or
unfortunately had passed away then you
know we couldn't you you know the
remaining data would be biased in favor
of those who were healthy and very low
you know we couldn't draw a correct
influence and it's difficult to detect
missing not at random oh because you
might have the known unknowns you know
what I mean by that in other words you
have to know what you don't know huh
of all of his craziness that's the one
thing I I've taken to heart is that
there are a lot of you know things you
know you don't know but frequently there
are the unknown the things that you
don't know that you don't know and that
is what's going to trip us up and
distinguish distinguishing eMAR from an
odd mnar can be difficult if not
impossible sometimes ok let's take a
look at littles m-car test
oh this was first written in 1988
oh the test is based on mean differences
across groups of subjects with the same
missing data pattern and since the power
of the test may be low it is prudent to
keep in mind that accepting the null
hypothesis of m-car in other words that
there is no difference between the
missingness and the observed you still
have to use your own judgment and
prudence you know it is not a an instant
cure and you know we can use it that way
but if you know for some reason that
there is a
another reason for the missingness then
you know littles will not conjure that
away it's when you believe that it is at
random and you have no other reason to
think otherwise that you can apply this
or hear it
excuse me here at Sarah we implemented
in SAS which usually is not my favorite
program I'm an hour guy but there's a
neat code that I got from Dan's Eltham
and all and it runs beautifully you can
get a point-and-click version and SPSS
for I think the package is four thousand
dollars or something I'm a lot cheaper
yeah so um both Eugenia Buddha and
myself have run the SAS code
successfully so you know call on us and
this would be an example if the p-value
is not significant then then you don't
have to then you can consider the data
missing completely and random and just
proceed with it okay um for example or
in a paper I was a co-author on with
shill Shenoy from Gerry friedlin swoop
we had plenty of missing data in a South
Africa study and we conducted it on into
four individual factors to create what
was called a lab laboratory clinical
severity index which is something that I
worked with with Sheila and in these
four tests are determined that the
missingness for hemoglobin Albu albumin
and alkaline phosphate were missing
completely at random cratan was not
however in order to save n basically I
created an index account of those you
know
laboratory things which ones were
abnormal in the wrong direction and gave
each individual account of them when we
combine those then voila through this
statistical sleight of hand that was
that instead of using the individual
scores using that it became missing
completely at random and we were able to
you know get it through the reviewers
etc okay um and incidentally that is
actually it is better to test everything
at once in other words you put in
instead of doing each variable with the
outcome variable because of alpha
inflation every time you run a test at
5% you know P equals 0.75 you Ritt you
know the error rate is additive actually
and keeps building up as you go so um
it's better to put everything together
and test it and these were the these
were the scores but this was the all
four count that said you know this is a
very specific example but I just wanted
to use it since it's published you know
Jenny Jenny you look confused
no that's an adequate well well no no
one's ignoring the thing it's just to
see you know these are all as you know
these are all indicators of organ
failure and to see if and it turns out
of all the tests these four the key that
you know if you don't have you know in
you know bad lab readings for these four
you were more likely to survive the
extensively resistant you know TB and
HIV co-infection okay but yeah it's a
very little valid but you know what's
the alternative just not publishing
anything okay okay now the the these are
a list of horrors that you should not do
complete case analysis or without doing
anything else just throw out the missing
and run your data and as we've seen this
can lead to a lot of problems earlier a
single imputation in other words just do
a regression a linear regression on the
known values and then pick the values
from the regression line does everyone
follow me or not
yeah you know pick the values on the
regression line and fill the man and I
what would be the problem with that
right off the bat can anyone take a
guess okay well if you are picking the
regression line then you're basically
suppressing the variation and decreasing
the variance you know so it's um they
also you know so obviously you know
you're asking for trouble they're
missing data indicator a missing
category and you can do that but
so you know it obviously can lead to
bias and then last observation carried
forward and this was done especially in
the 60s and 70s um and I know those of
you in clinical medicine will probably
go oh my god you know did they really do
this they did in other words you know
here are the values and well that one
was a 24 and again you were suppressing
variation pretty seriously and all but
defeating the purpose of a longitudinal
study if you do too much of this okay so
um carry-all there was a really good
paper and I will send you all the
references to a little you know of
littles test talked about Bayesian
algorithms which are model based in
contrast to these older imputation
methods um
so we already went over the dis there
were things like hot deck and so forth
and so on which you don't do but a model
for data is defined and then it results
in the likelihood or posterior
distribution of the law of the model and
the estimates in general including those
of the variances can be formed to
account for the missing data and this
before multiple imputation came into its
own within the last couple of years was
a very good alternative to missing data
and it was done in something how many of
you know what wind bugs is know okay um
it was a joint
endeavor between the MRC biostatistics
Unit at Cambridge and the Department of
Epidemiology and public health of
Imperial College of London and it stands
for Bayesian forget the eye inference
using Gibbs sampling and wind bugs just
means it runs in Windows originally you
know was designed for Lenox space
and how many of you use Ubuntu by any
chance
no no Linux based Oh Lord yeah you all
this free weird you know all the stuff
that's available
no no viruses no you know root kits no
well but at a rate you win bugs runs
perfectly well in Windows um it can
handle analysis for complex statistical
models missing data measurement error an
important point is there's no
closed-form for the posterior
distribution and um the Bayesian
posterior inference is a che achieved
through a Markov chain Monte Carlo
integration ok duh how many of you are
familiar with what a Markov chain is let
me just take a second a Markov chain
means that only the immediate previous
observation informs the current one Oh
for example an example I use is someone
goes to a bar starts drinking and starts
doing 90 miles per hour and runs the car
to a tree
ok the previous state that he was doing
90 miles per hour is informative of the
outcome the fact that he was doing 30
miles per hour before that and that the
car was parked before that are
irrelevant so just to give you an idea
on so however wind bugs is not for the
faint of heart I this is an example
using non informative priors with what's
called a half normal distributions with
50,000 iterations and a burning of 4,000
other words you you actually are going
to work
you know forty forty six thousand and
that's page one and that's page two oh
no this is in wind bugs and there's a
bug star um so let's go most of you who
were casually dealing with missing data
are not going to sit down and learn wind
bugs and really you don't have to you
know one you could ask me if you thought
that was the best way to go and I would
do all this but or Eugenia who is got
her PhD in Bayesian analysis but
generally we are recommending multiple
imputation if you can satisfy the mcar
or ma r conditions you know and actually
in Bayesian analysis will not help you
if you are missing not at random you're
just kind of you know apply for more
grant funds or something okay oh this
time we're going to perform amputations
of the missing data m times usually five
and then the datasets are analyzed
separately and the results across the
analysis are are combined and i'll get
into that and this would be an example
of multiple imputation where you had
missingness and it would fill in five
different datasets so to speak so in
plan d since you looked at the wind bugs
instructions and threw your hands up o
would be to use the amelia package and
are and it is indeed name for Amelia
Erhart rather whimsically as a symbol of
missingness I always that's a bit dark
but um what do all of you know what R is
yes yes okay well briefly it's both a
program and a software package it's
derived from the S program
language are created by John Chambers
who is not the same John Chambers that
what do you call it the chairman of the
board who's you know the very prominent
Republican donor it's not him and anyway
the cart cart version was developed in
New Zealand by and it's freeware and
open-source there's no charge and the
underlying code is available to anybody
and that's why there's so much in it and
it has become the de-facto gold standard
oh it's considered the most publishable
most consistent and along with the
standard software there are almost 3,000
specialized tats specific add-on
packages laden class analysis survival
analysis you know just anything you can
think of there's a package you can add
on and I would like to add that you know
as freeware with multiple people across
different countries and cultures
there's a wonderful absence of jargon
and program specific language the
instructions are in English the error
messages in the when you if you make a
goof it says there's an error on line
five you know that's it it doesn't say
code five five five you know and all
this other nonsense the version we're
going to use is the package developer
developed by Honaker King and block well
and it was just revised and updated on
April 3rd so this is as up-to-date as
you're going to get folks okay what
exactly does Emil you do it resamples
the original data set using a bootstrap
algorithm it implements an expectation
maximization algorithm and on an
expectation maximization algorithm is an
iterative method of finding the maximum
likelihood or the maximum all APIs terry
estimates of parameters in statistical
models
okay and don't worry I will send you
these slides you can look up the terms
in depth and it uses all of the data to
estimate the missing values if you think
about it a sample even a large one even
with a large amount of missingness is
basically one realization of the data
you know a sort of possible reality if
you think about it an amelia creates
other realizations of the data using the
aforementioned algorithms you know what
we see when we sample is just one
possibility really
and these amelia the default is set to
five so you know that usually is enough
realities for most people and so all
five are combined to a apply standard
statistical analysis and further reduce
bias and this is done within amelia they
use Zelig which is every man's
statistical package to do this also you
know named after the Woody Allen movie
but at any rate um and that's how it
works
so um as we've said it can multiply
missing data in a single cross-section
such as a survey from time series like
variables collected for each year in a
country or from a time series 12
sectional data such as collected by
years for each of several country as
I've said it implements a bootstrapping
algorithm that gives essentially the
same answer since the standard approach
but it's faster and can handle many more
variables and it's basically a faster
than the proc mi and SAS for those of
you fought with that thing and um it
basically generalizes the existing
approaches by allowing for trends in
time series across observations within a
cross-sectional unit as well as prior
that allow experts to incorporate
beliefs they have about the values of
the missing data in their cell okay and
there's a GUI with it so all of this
once you set it up it can be
point-and-click
you know it'll look just like a you know
simple SPSS package or something you
just say impute this and it will map the
missingness for you and here is the code
compared to the wind bugs you know this
is the you know you've got to set the
number of mutations you want or just
said this will give you five which is
what everyone uses what it's published
that's the data set
damn done it's not perfect and I thought
in all fairness I should show you one of
my
mishaps here here is the observed data
okay in black and here where the mean
the mean amputate amputations so I in
fact I did have to go back and tweak it
a little bit it generally but it gives
you these dotted sort of graphs to see
whether or not you're off you know
completely you know off in doing this
okay so as I said the purpose today
basically was to let you all know what
we can do for you
okay for any surra affiliated research
we can do a little test for you okay
just send us the data and the variables
that you want us to see you know and the
obviously you know the outcome and
hopefully the explanatory variables or
what have you we can do the Bayesian
simulations
um we can explore the missingness using
I didn't go over this but we could also
do t-tests and things like that to see
how different the people who are missing
are from those who have complete data
and for anyone who wants it I can sit
down and either do the multiple include
imputation for you or take about 15 to
20 minutes and teach you how to do it in
are like I said because it has its own
GUI you don't even have to know are you
know you there's no big coding there's
that one line and then a few other
adjustments if the mapping or the
graphing of the imputation as I showed
you it doesn't look so great okay well
thank you for your attention